hey good humans jason from jubilee here
at the jubilee office i just want to
take a moment to say thank you to
the ridge wallet for sponsoring this
episode
i honestly just got this wallet and i
think it's incredible
i think it looks super dope really
really sleek
super thin and also really really
durable it's amazing and it has a full
lifetime
warranty
it can hold up to 12 cards which is a
big concern sometimes i have with
thin wallets and has space for your cash
as well
i highly recommend it i've loved
carrying it around they've got over 30
different options for colors
uh you can have carbon fiber burnt
titanium i honestly love it so much i
might get a second one just so i can
kind of switch out the colorways there's
also even a 45-day guarantee
so if you get it and you don't love it
you can always send it back for a full
refund so there is no risk
if you use our code jubilee you actually
get 10 off make sure you check them out
and with father's day around the corner
this could be the perfect gift for your
father
or honestly yourself or your mother
anyone really
uh make sure you check out ridgewater
thank you again for the sponsorship
and we hope you enjoy this episode who's
a makeup artist off the top of your head
that you like
maybe not idolize what you look up to
that was amazing
we brought together seven makeup artists
i am a makeup artist
i'm a makeup artist i am a makeup artist
i'm a makeup artist
i'm a makeup artist i'm a makeup artist
i am a makeup artist
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is
they'll split a cash prize
if the liar survives they win the entire
prize
who is the odd one out
[Music]
i was just like staring at everyone
trying to see who was staring at each
other and i was like kind of confused at
first of what was going on
[Music]
i kind of assumed that everybody would
be coming in with a full face of makeup
so when aldrich came in
and he didn't have any specific eye look
i'm kind of thinking
huh maybe he doesn't really do makeup
[Music]
i felt like everyone was going to
eliminate me right away just because
i was definitely a bit extra
[Music]
to me it didn't really seem like a
professional it seems like someone who
is just trying to experiment with
everything that they had in their kit
[Music]
okay bye guys i felt
so sad being the first person eliminated
i don't know
what it was i'd like to know have any of
y'all worked with celebrities
influencers influencers i've never
worked with a celebrity okay who have
you all worked with
not everybody like knows her but her
name's yvette she has followers
yeah like about a million so most of you
guys are like
youtube i just do makeup like no youtube
or anything okay
but i almost work with like exotic
dancers and stuff
oh cool i do like weddings stuff like
that so if people have events where they
can reach out to me
and have me go there then that's what i
do i hate bridal
i get this a lot since i'm like
extravagant like like stuff and like
do people look at you and then like
wouldn't want a natural look because
they think you yep all the time one time
i had like this customer
she kind of like prejudged me based off
like my makeup because it was kind of
like yours like really artsy
yeah and her daughter was like going to
prom and she's like i don't want that
and i was like i'm not gonna do that i
always get worried about that because
like as a
male makeup artist i always like okay
well are they going to judge me because
they don't think that i can
am capable of doing this makeup and then
just like i'm like
please just trust the process like trust
the process
what's like the average price of like a
makeover if one just wanted like a
natural glam
depends on the product i was gonna say
like a hundred plus fifty dollar kid fee
okay i'll give you number maybe like um
200 plus a hundred dollar kit fee
okay come on so i charge 200. just flat
but after that depending on how long it
takes i'll charge extra per hour
and you just do beauty yeah pretty much
i
wanted to sound more legitimate
but that doesn't really make sense that
would be like a long time
doing somebody's makeup who's a makeup
artist off the top of your head that you
like
and maybe not idolize what you look up
to manny
that was amazing for myself probably
like kevin aquan
i love kevin aquan okay michelle phan
kind of raised me so i i gotta get to
michelle
i'm really big in like youtube and like
online so i really like mickey tutorials
i was suspicious of alice because she
was eyeballing me since i came in
when she mentioned anything about like
youtube i was like
okay there's like some issues with you
know people's backgrounds
so like it's hard to separate the art in
the person
we got shut up now
[Music]
i was going to change it i stuck with my
first guest she didn't get voted out in
the first round so i just voted for her
again
[Music]
[Applause]
bye guys i'm
feeling sad but not super surprised
i think that the tension got to me
all right if you want to continue
playing please raise your hand
this is the eye makeup challenge you
guys will have three minutes to put on
makeup on
our model darren
[Music]
we will start off with nikki
can i hold the products sure you can
hold the product
you know we would never normally use a
liquid liner on somebody
[Laughter]
i knew i was going to get called first
too so i definitely
had a lot of pressure put on me in that
i'm going to have you match me
all right the black is not pigmented at
all
[Music]
okay hello my name is aldridge i'll be
your makeup artist for today
if you can just look down for me i can't
if you can look up for me
cute with the etiquette throw in though
i should have asked if you were allergic
to anything but
oh well let's just pack on more color
he only did one eye which is okay and i
know we only have three minutes but i
just want to see more from him
i have gloves i came ready
my time's not going okay
i told you i'll work with dancers like
they give me 30 seconds to do their
makeup
[Music]
that was so good
bentley killed it i think i did the best
i think i did amazing
time george will be your makeup artist
today so what do you do in your story
time
you model often you have a gorgeous skin
what is your skin prep like
water just water
that's it i'm done okay do you mind if i
use my fingers on your face
okay i'm gonna try to see if i can pick
up some more pigment
[Music]
okay so i'm going to go for like a cute
little
graphic moment so a little tapping
motion you know
that's how you apply some shadow try to
outline this with the liner my hand is
shaking so
oh you're giving it
[Music]
i felt like that was like a good choice
to do something graphic i don't know if
maybe i
did the worst because i was panicking
[Music]
to get rid of the competition
we have a tie between aldrich and
george period that means we're going
into a tiebreaker
each of you is going to get 20 seconds
to state your case
so we'll start with aldrich i'm a makeup
artist i've been working for a since
2015. i started at a haunted house
starting doing special effects makeup
and then
i decided to perfect my craft moved here
and then started freelancing i've been
working with only fans people so i've
worked with bella thorne tyler posey pia
mia
kid quill and i'm still trying to build
up my portfolio
but i'm a makeup artist
so when i was growing up it wasn't cool
to be a makeup artist so throughout my
time and age i had to originally paint
my face inside of my um room
and as i got older i learned through
youtube and
all my friends were makeup artists and
it's really a creative outlet for me i
love being able to create a new face for
myself and other people i love
challenges
i love all uh facets of the makeup
artist and i'm a makeup artist
that tiebreaker had me shook i was like
oh i'm out okay well all right well it
was nice knowing y'all
please raise your hand if you have any
doubts and if you want to continue
playing the game
you're beautiful but i like totally
forgot your story and everything because
you were really quiet
um how did you start off i just remember
you saying you liked the fenty artist
and that was like all i got i'm sorry
since growing up i've always loved
makeup so i started with family friends
in high school i graduated around
2015. i worked at mac for about three
years i've been doing makeup on people
there and then started freelancing
there what lashes do you have on these
are by dynasty cosmetics
i don't remember the name but they're
like a more of an indie smaller brand do
you have a pr code
no i don't okay yeah you're like thank
you
no i was just actually okay i continued
the page i could see this i was just
asking i think it might be you because
i don't know you're just so beautiful by
someone else did your makeup and then my
doubt for you is
you're kind of asking us questions so we
don't have a chance to answer i was
going to say you can bring back to me
shoot away well can you give us like a
like a rundown yeah of course
um i started off in musical theater i
was a musical theater major most of my
life which is like
which is why she's like this i'm like
i would always help like the dancers out
with their lashes and this is not even
in theater and again like you kind of
know about makeup in that way
and then i just kind of decided that was
what i wanted to
pursue what's your favorite part about
being a makeup artist mine is making
people happy and making them like
something that they never imagined they
could be i like giving people confidence
that they don't think they have kind of
building their confidence confidence as
well but just kind of like making their
day because like sometimes
just talking to them and not even
besides the makeup helps build their day
and
you take a little therapy session yeah
exactly i'm a color theory snob so i
love anything as far as like blending
that's why even like clean skin
is my go-to and a just likes to
create weird oh my god i'm cursing
so much
okay so yeah can the mall raise their
hand oh that didn't work
that's the sad part now now we have to
vote someone else so it's like but i
know they're gone
it's too late we already we already know
the next round
again i'm so sorry like i love you like
can we be friends on instagram please
[Music]
okay bye we love you we love you
so please raise your hand if you want to
continue playing in three
two one
if the light turns green that means you
have voted out the mole and you win
if the light turns red that means the
mole is still in the box
and you lose oh my gosh
yes okay yes thank you
oh my goodness i have the doubts on you
will the mole please step forward and
reveal yourself in three
two one sorry guys
you guys normally i'm what you paint did
you do your makeup this morning no one
of my girlfriends did
but i can do makeup but nothing like you
guys you guys are amazing i was obsessed
with your eyes obsessed with your eyes
obsessed with your self
makeup artists are the best people in
the world and everybody that we had here
today i could honestly say i could beat
my face
it was so much fun i feel amazing
i thought i was going to be the first
one out because i didn't have any makeup
on and
i was like these people are gonna hate
me but no i'm happy i won
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey come on